alors un futur bébé héritiers de
l'héritier défénestré un mariage forcé
avec un mort vous même séquestré et tout
ce beau monde qui s'appelle
presqu'unanimement augusto là j'avoue je
suis un peu dépassé
on va recommencer l'appui que nous donne
de ses nouvelles
si elle est mariée au brésil passemar au
brésil cette [ __ ] safar nos canaux
calcule pas il faudrait qu'on rate et
comme des chiennes bas franchement moi
je veux être une chaîne au brésil
[ __ ] [ __ ] le but
[Musique]
katia cl on le confesse zinio ses
augustes aux juniors c'est le mort nous
on est là par amitié
c'est tellement son mariage et son beau
père qu'il consistante à la sacem
ce qu'on appelle les flics on leur
explique que comprendre que c'était un
minimoy on leur dit quoi retrouve le mec
il est pas mon avis c'est surtout la
taille de l'immeuble il a juste un petit
peu mal aux couilles je pense que c'est
le moment de faire l'amour tout mon
beau-père vous nous voyez mon bébé j'ai
tout papier son propre pays dans le dos
j'ai plus qu'à me tirer une balle vous
voulez arrêter avec ce vaste 2100 c'est
à cause duquel j'ai quitté la france
merci
hahaha
m
brutal et à l'escwa salle à tue tête
décroisée à tout-va l'hortus où les
choses il a commencé de la tâche
tu sais ce que tu vas t'éclater la
gueule sans ton [ __ ] bolland qui
pourra même plus et c'est quelqu'un ça
va très bien nous faire rire
qu'est ce que c'est
c'était une tenace et ça va être une
bonne état nation
[Musique]